alors première séquence christian
lacroix nous dit rien par contre il a
déclaré dans un journal
ma femme et mon conseiller ont tout fait
pour moi alors ce soir on a réuni
beaucoup plus que ta femme et ton
conseillère d'origine toute la maison
lacroix
je voudrais que tout le monde là après
l'autre me dise ce qu'il a apporté à la
maison lacroix jean jacques picart le
conseiller on commence par toi
je cherche que j'apportais à cheikh
kanté ou suis sincère et je dis tout un
master la sincère j'ai tout à porter et
suisse je suis modeste dj rien apporté
parce qu'il avait déjà tout donc c'est
une question un peu
non je crois qu'on a rien le succès
médiatique de la croix tu n'es pas un
peu pour quelque chose
c'est une technique mais j'ai travaillé
pour beaucoup de stylistes ils n'étaient
pas tous capables de décrocher autant de
pages autant d' espaces dans les médias
que lacroix donc je crois qu'un peu de
technique
s'il ya rien à donner ça sert pas à
grand chose un peu technique beaucoup de
talent beaucoup de charme ça ça donne
beaucoup de résultats dont je crois
qu'on a rien apporté une avait tout en
lui on a peut-être juste aider à
exprimer
très bien paulo draps vous êtes
président de la maison lacroix le pdg
nous représenter des rares nos dans la
maison on vous voit rarement la
télévision rarement les journaux je
serais content que soigner là ce soir
qu'est ce que vous avez apporté à la
maison lacroix ou combien
le groupe de bernard arnault d'avoir
participé avec la vie nancy ragage un
apport financier important et nécessaire
pour lancer une maison de couture ou
blanc l'international
quant à quentin moi mon rôle consiste à
faire en sorte que christian soit euros
et qu'on accélère squire on essaie de
satisfaire les uns et les autres c'est
difficile ah non ça se passe très bien
parce que nous avons sommes tous en main
christian et tous les ans dans cette
maison il te manque de fautes lui même
longueur d'onde et que par conséquent où
tout est parti d'un pli site amputation
très bien des choses ce portrait
merveilleusement bien
françoise captieux apporté à christian
lacroix un kit quartier moi je suis la
face cachée de la maison un croisement
c'est la face camarguaise d'accroître
les vacances sont un moyen de chez moi
des compressions bien pensants et puis
s'en vont ils sont contents en fait je
suis gentil organisateur de leurs
vacances ils sont contentés vacances oh
oui je pense qu'ils reviennent
bon je le connaisse ou une autre phase
je vous dirai pas laquelle on en parlera
après oui alors lisabeth garouste et
mattia bonetti à part la décoration de
la maison lacroix rue du faubourg
saint-honoré
qu'est ce que vous avez apporté à
christian lacroix
le départ mais avec
complicité
le temps
qui s'est fait un peu sans parler comme
ça très effectivement né comme disait
paul aux draps sans la même longueur
d'onde je crois au maintien mais moi je
crois que nous construit et l'aspect ce
décret autour d'un bijou qu'est
christian il est trés gracié c'est le
sujet qui a fait le sait déjà pas témoin
avant vous aussi vous êtes pas rappelé
christian tu n'as pas le droit de parler
toi là tout de suite tu n'as pas de
micro marmaris et ce n'est que le
comment on dit l'égérie le mannequin
vedette mais il peut pas lui même ami
c'est exprès je travaille pour christ
tu lui apporte un peu c'est je crois que
tu là quand il a besoin pour
ces soirées aussi puisque tu vas bientôt
se marier avec hubert boukobza coup quel
patron de l'endroit l'hiver est au
courant viviane m'en parler m'a dit que
ça pouvait l'annoncé voilà pour tout le
monde
alors maintenant on va voir un sujet qui
a été fait par notre ami franck maubert
où on voit les gens qui travaillent chez
lacroix 73 faubourg saint-honoré qui
parle du patron alors si on peut envoyer
un sujet tu n'as rien à dire tu n'as pas
de micro non plus alors maintenant sujet
métro